موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قال مسؤول الرفيع
في البيت الابيض ان الرئيس الاوكرانيه
فولدومر سيزور واشنطن اليوم بدعوه من
الرئيس جوبادل وذكر المسؤول ان بيض سيعلن
عن حزمه مساعدات جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه
مليارين دولار تشمل صواريخ بتروت وقنابل
دقيقه واضاف ان زياره زيليسكي رساله دعم
ومؤازره لاوكرانيا وان الرئيس بيدن لن
يمارس اي ضغوط على نظيره الاوكراني كما
قال المسؤول الامريكي
سيلقي كلمه في الكونجرس بعد لقائه بيضا
واكد ان واشنطن تدعم الشعب الاوكرانيه
لكنها لا تسعى للمخرات في حرب مباشره
قال الرئيس الروسي ان بلاده تتعرض مره
اخرى للتحدي واقر بصعوبه الوضع في مناطق
لوجان
وزبوجيا واعتبر بوتين ان الجنود الروسي
يظهرون امثله استثنائيه في شجاعه خلال
القتال في اوكرانيا حسب تعبير
قال مراسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي من
الولايات المتحده لا تتوقع حدوث تقدم في
الاتفاق النووي الايراني في المستقبل واكد
كربيان الاتفاق النوويه مع ايران ليس محطه
تركي الان
في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف انه التقى مع
وزير الخارجيه الايراني
وسط تدهور العلاقات بين ايران والاتحاد
الاوروبي واشار بريل الى انه اتفق مع عبد
الله هيان على ضروره ابقاء قنوات التواصل
مفتوحه واستعاده الاتفاق النووي على اساس
مفاوضات
بدوره قال وزير الخارجيه الايراني ان
بلاده ستدعم احياء الاتفاق النووي طالما
تم احترام خطوطها الحمراء ومستعده للخطوه
النهائيه لابرام الاتفاق واكيد عبد الله
هيان على ضروره ابتعاد الاطراف الاخرى عن
تاسيس الملف
في تونس اعلنت حركه النهضه اعتقال نائب
رئيس الحركه ورئيس الحكومه الاسبق علي
العريض فيما تعرف بقضيه التسير وقالت
الحركه ان هدف الاعتقال هو التغطيه على
مسمته الفشل في الانتخابات بدورها اعتبر
جبهه الخلاص المعارضون الاجراء يفتقر
للاسس القانونيه من جهه انتقد الرئيس
التونسيه والتركيزه على ضعف نسبه المشاركه
في الاقتراع لتشكيكه في شرعيه البرلمان
بينما دعت اتحاد الشغل للحوار للخروج من
الازمه
في تجميد
على المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده السلطات التونسيه الى ضمان احترام
حقوقي رئيس الحكومه التونسيه السابق علي
العريض بما في ذلك ما يتعلق بالاجراءات
القانونيه
لقي طفله مصرعهما جرى السيول والامطار
الغزيره التي تعرضت لها مدينه بورتسودان
عاصمه ولايه البحر الاحمر شمال شرقي سودان
وقال شهود عيان نسيو الغامرت احد الاسواق
الرئيسه وعددا من الاحياء في المدينه التي
تضم الميناء الرئيسي للبلاد على البحر
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]